[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم لماذا كل هذه القسوه في حق من
يعبر عن تعاطفه مع قطر في الحصار الذي فرض
عليها ما الذي يدعو دولا تقول انها تملك
البراهين التي تبرر قراراتها ضد الدوحه
الى مصادره حريه مواطنيها في مناقشه
العاصفه التي المت بالبيت الخليجي فضلا
على انتقاد حكام فيما ذهبوا اليه من
قرارات اسئله فرضتها مفارقه استوقفت
كثيرين فقطر التي حصرتها المزاعم والحملات
التحريضيه وما تلاها من قرارات لم تضيق اي
واسع في حريه التعبير بينما الدول حاصره
تترصد باشد العقوبات التغريدات والتدوينات
وكل المواقف التي لا تتناغم والازمه التي
افتعلتها وفرضتها على المنطقه والعالم
تقرير فاطمه التريكي ثم نشرع في
النقاش يقال ان اسوا ما في الخوف هو الخوف
نفسه حين يدفع صاحبه للهرب مما يظنه سيئا
فيقع في الاسوا حال دول الخليج المقاطعه
لقطر يحمل مؤشرات تتجاوز وصفها بالخائن
مازوم بعد يومين من قرار الحصار في الخامس
من هذا الشهر اعلنت الامارات والسعوديه
والبحرين عن عقوبات اذهلت الحقوقيين
والناس جميعا السجن حتى 15 عاما لمن يكتب
تعاطفا او محاباه لدوله شقيقه عربيه
ومسلمه اما الغرامات فثوره نصف مليون
دولار وفي موازه بداهه تقول ان من يخاف
شيئا يمنعه يذهب تحليل الى ان ترك الفضاء
الالكتروني الوسيله الوحيده للتعبير الحر
في الدول الثلاث يشي على الارجح بان
اكثريه الراي العام فيها معارض لقرارات
حكوماته او ان هذه عاجزه عن اقناعه لذا
تركت الميدان
للمناصرة تطر في المزعوم فهذا الفضاء نفسه
شاهد على الاف المغردين من هذه الدول
يناصرون علنا ما توصف باكثر التنظيمات
تشددا دون ان تلاحقهم العيون
المستاجره العقوبات الجديده تنفذ فعلا في
البحرين التي تسجن حاليا محاميا ضبط
متلبسا يغرد في حين تكفلت تنبيهات زاجره
مثل هذا الاكاديمي في اسكان
وتخويف الباقين يكشف ذلك براي كثيرين عن
شرخ بين هذه الحكومات وشعوبها فتضطر الى
قمعها بطريقه حديديه لمجرد الكلام فماذا
لو فعلت شيئا اخر وبهذا تظهر هذه الدول
امام العالم كله بعدما وصمت عشرات الافراد
والكيانات بالارهاب وهي تنتهك حقوق
مواطنيها بحسب تعبير مفوض الامم المتحده
لحقوق الانسان فيما تحدثت را وش عن
محاولات فاشله لغسل العقول ووصفتها منظمه
العفو الدوليه بالاجراءات التعسفيه لدول
لديها سجل في قمع التعبير السلمي في
المقابل فان السلطات القطريه لم تقفل فضاء
ولم تهدد او تطرد احدا واقتصاديا تقول قطر
ان كل دولار تخسره يقابله دولار في الدول
المحاصره اما في السياسه للمحاصرين
فتذبل عليه سوى ثلاثه اسابيع من الاتهامات
ولوائح الارهاب قالت الامم المتحده انها
لا تعني شيئا ثم يخرج وزير الخارجيه
السعودي ليتحدث الان عن تحضير لائحه شكاوى
لقطر بازار خسائر مرتده يقود الى تساؤلات
حقيقيه لدى المتابع عن امتلاك قاده هذه
السياسات رجاحه فكر كافيه تدير دولا
وتؤتي شعوب والى مقارنه حداثه تبنى على
قيم واسس ووهم اخرى تناطح السحاب وتخنق
التغريد وللحديث عن هذا الموضوع معنا من
الكويت عيد الفضلي الكاتب الصحفي الكويتي
وعبر سكايب من لندن دروري دايك الباحث في
منظمه العفو الدوليه مرحبا بكما سيد دايك
كيف تفهم هذا القرار القاضي باخراج ازمه
العلاقه مع قطر من دائره النقاش العام
وتجريم الخوض فيها اصلا او ابداء الراي
اذاعها في
الواقع
ان ان
هذه هذا حدث لا سابقه له في منطقه الخليج
وان ان
ان قمع حريه التعبير و هذه في هذه
المناسبه يسيء الى او يدهور وضع هو في
الاصل ضعيف وغير جيد فيما يتعلق بحريه
الكلام والتعبير فعلى س المثال
في جرائم السيبيريه في 2012 في
الامارات تمثل او تدعو او تمثل جانب ممكن
متابعه
قانونيه ما قامت
ب مثلا المحكمه المتخصصه في
السعوديه الذي
تستخدم مسائل غريبه لهد الناس وماساه
التكم في الوضع الحالي هي ان هذا هذا
السياق الضعيف ل ل حيث انه اصلا حريه
التعبير معرضه لهجوم في هذا هذه الدول
وحصل فيها اضطهادات ومقدمات محكما محاكم
كثير من داعين حقوق الانسان لكن الماساه
هذه المره ان الذين يريدون التعبير عن
ارائهم والاحتجاج حول كيف يمكن لمثل هذه
الاجراءات ان تؤثر
عليهم الاسر المشتركه وعلى الذي يعملون في
الدول الاخرى مثلا قطر يعملون في الامارات
او المواطنين اماراتيين يعملون في قطر ما
ال ذلك لو تجروا الحديث على وقول شيء ح
يتعرضون للاضطهاد والمحاكمه وهذه الدول
فعلا قالت انهم ستعاقب من يقوم بذلك
وبالتالي فهذا يضيف ويضاعف الماساه ازاء
ما يقدم الانذار النهائي الاعتباطي الذي
فرض وبالذات هذه ماساه صنعتها هذه الدول
بيدها سيد الفضلي بالمقابل وبالمقارنة
جها قطر في هذه الازمه وهل بدا ان هناك في
تعدد الاراء حول هذا الحصار ومزاعمه ما
يزعجها ما
يقلقها مساك الله بالخير اخوي
الحبيب بدايه احب ان اشكر قناه الجزيره
على انضباطها الاعلامي خلال هذه الازمه
الخليجيه فلم تنزل الى مستوى الاعلامي
الذي يقول المعده القطريه لا تهضم اللبن
التركي و ابشر ان المعده القطريه بخير
وممكن ان تهضم الحاشي والمفاطيح
وغيره عوده الى سؤالك اخي
الحبيب جميع الاجراءات اللي قامت فيها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وكذلك الامارات
والبحرين ومصر وبعض الدول هذه الاجراءات
لم تجد لها صد في الشارع لم تجد رده فعل
حيث يكون هناك قطع للارحام والعائلات وبعض
الامور الانسانيه من الامور الانسانيه
هناك مواطن
قطري زوجته سعوديه موجود في
الكويت وكان دخل الكويت عن طريق البر لما
بدات الازمه ماذا فعل قام بحجز تذكره الى
زوجته لتعود الى المملكه وهو موجود في
الكويت ويريد الرجوع الى قطر طبعا راح
يرجع جوا سيارته هل يشحنها ام انه يخليها
يامنها في الكويت كذلك هناك حالات انسانيه
بين ابو ظبي وقطر هناك عوائل مشتركه نصف
العائله في قطر والنصف الاخر في الامارات
كيف التواصل القطريون المتزوجون من
سعوديات وبحريني واماراتيات ماذا ما هو
مصيرهم لماذا نصل الى هذه الحاله كل الذي
اريده ان اناشد المسؤولين في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ان يقومون بتنفيذ الامر
الملكي الصادر من خادم الحرمين الشريفين
بمراعاه الحالات الانسانيه مراعاه الحالات
الانسانيه تريد يعني يجب ان يكون هناك
مركز بين البلدين يعمل مركز حدودي فماذا
لو انا مثلا من اصحاب الثروه الحيوانيه
ولدي ثروه حيوانيه في المملكه من الابل
وغيره كيف ادخلهم الى قطر والمركز
مغلق من لديه سي سياره معطله من لديه
بضائع في المملكه ما مصير هذا فعلا القرار
كان غير مدروس ا طيب سيد دايك نركز اكثر
على هذه الاجراءات والعقوبات التي اتخذت
بحق كل من يبدي حتى مجرد التعاطف مع قطر
نتحدث عن يعني عقوبات تصل الى 15 سنه عن
غرامات ماليه كبيره هل تراها تتناسب مع
الجرم المفترض وهو ابداء التعاطف مع
قطر كلا اطلاقا اطلاقا لا يتناسب وان
التعبير التعبير المسالم السلمي عن الراي
لا يمكن لا يمكن يعتبر دعوه او تشجيع
للعنف ولا
يؤسس شكلا من العنف باي
نوع من الواضح هذا مجرد انه الشخص يمارس
حقه وحقها
في في التعبير او حريه التعبير التعبير
السلمي للاراء هو من الحقوق
الاساسيه وان اعتقال المحامي البحريني
لهذا السبب يثبت ويبين مع الاسف مدى الياس
والصعوبه
التي التي خلقتها هذه المشكله او هذا
الوضع
وكما ق كنتم لمحت في سؤالكم ان مجرد
التعبير عن القلق مثلا فيما يتعلق بهذا
الوضع الذي قد سمم شخصا قطريا او شخصا من
دوله اخرى يمكن ان يدفع بشخص الى غيا
بالسجون ويضعه في ضمن الانتقال وبالتالي
هذه كارثه ماساه ومع الاسف ان ان هذا كله
يبين ان هناك
احتقار للكرامه
الانسانيه سيد الفضلي يعني رغم ان الازمه
والقضيه لها بعض الحساسيه السياسيه وحتى
الامنيه بتقديرك لماذا لم تنجر قطر الى
هذا الاسلوب الزجري الذي تتبعته الدول
المحاصره بمصادره حريه التعبير عن
الراي اخي غط اعلنت انها ملتزمه بمبادئ
مجلس التعاون الخليجي وانها ما زالت عضو
في مجلس التعاون الخليجي وبالنهايه نحن
اشقاء رده الفعل لا يجب ان تكون كما كان
الفعل الفعل الذي صدر فعل غاسي فعل لم
يتمتع باي مباد لحقوق الانسان حرم بعض
العائلات من التواصل فيما بينهما
كذلك الفعل هذا عندما انا يعني اضرب لك
مثلا هناك دكتور اكاديمي اماراتي غرد
تغريده عمل فيها استفتاء هل تؤيدون الحصار
على قطر ام ترفضون وهو قال مغاطع وليس
كمان حصار فجاءت النتيجه
65% قام بحذف هذا الاستفتاء خوفا من
المسائله قد يكون ه الاستفتاء يوديه 15
عاما في السجن فيجب ان نفتح حريه الراي
نحن شعب واحد في الخليج من الكويت الى ان
لا فرق بيننا يجب ان نعبر عن راينا يجب ان
نتعاطف وفقا لمبادئ حقوق الانسان
كاتفاقية ستسبب كارثه اقتصاديه لمصر ومصر
حاليا تعاني ازمه اقتصاديه فقطر مشكوره
نات بنفسها عن هذه المشاكل وعن رده الفعل
وتحملت القرار واوجد البدائل حتى يكون
الشعب القطري في احسن حال ان شاء الله سيد
دايك يعني في
المطلق الفضاءات فضاءات التواصل يعني
اصبحت مفتوحه بين الجميع وهناك توق بشري
وطبيعي لهذا التواصل للتعبير عن الراي
يعني هذه الممارسات في التضييق والخنق الى
اي حد يمكن ان تنتج مفاعيل
عكسيه نعم نعم هذا هو فعل المصدر قلق
حقيقي وهو سؤال وجيه فالتاريخ
والخبره
خبره كثير من الدول في كثير من فترات
المختلفه فعلا تشير الى وجود ازمه كبيره
جدا وان حريه التعبير والسماح للناس
بالتعبير عن ارائهم بطريقه سلميه يشكل
صمام امان ويمنح
الناس فرصه للحصول على معلومات راجعه ورده
فعل لكي ينفس فيها عن الضغوط اللي يعتم
وبالتالي فهذا جزء اساسي ومهم من اي دوله
واي شعب يريد ان
يتطور ويتطور ويطور الامور بشكل بحيث ان
البنى الاجتماعيه تكون امنه وسالمه وان
اغلاق صمام الامان هذا واغلاق هذا الاسلوب
بدل فتحه يمكن ان للدول المعنيه ان تمر
بخطر كبير وتزيد من الضغوط على الناس
وبالتالي في بعض الاحيان زيا الضغط يكون
بشكل كبير وبالتالي هذا تصرف او اجراء خطر
جدا اشكرك سيد دروري دايك الباحث في منظمه
العفو الدوليه واشكر السيد عبد عيد الفضلي
الكاتب الصحفي الكويتي شكرا لكم